Yet another twist in the
Sam Altman
saga at Open
AI just days after its board fired
him, allowing him
and some key deputies
to be hired by Microsoft.
He is back at the top of OpenAI,
a company
saying in a statement
that it had reached an agreement
in principle to rehire Altman
and has also met demands
to revamp the board of directors.
CNN contributor Kara Swisher
joining us now.
She is also, of course,
the host of the On and Pivot podcast.
Good to see you this morning, Kara.
So, you know,
you kind of feel that you saw this
or you saw this
coming of the reporting
that it was coming,
the fact that we are in this place
this morning.
Sam Altman coming back, a new board.
What does it mean
Well, it's kind of a new board.
One of the old board
members, Adam D'Angelo,
who used to be a Facebook executive
and he started Quora, is still on it.
They brought in Brett Taylor,
who was the chairman of Twitter,
and sold that to Elon Musk.
He was also at Facebook, I believe,
and Larry Summers,
I don't know where he came from.
But there he is,
obviously the Harvard
economist, Treasury Department
and Harvard. Yeah.
Yeah.
So it's
they replaced the board that was there
which was a very small board
because they hadn't replaced
previous people with left.
So I expect it to get bigger.
I expect Microsoft
to have seats on the board.
I guess
they might try to find a woman, maybe,
you know, three white guys.
It's kind of Silicon Valley
might be an audition.
Yeah, I think it's going to be of much.
Yeah, it might be.
It's it'll probably be ten person board
or nine or ten at least.
And and it changes it considerably
in terms of of who
what kind of people are on it.
And it's it's much more professional.
Much more techie.
That's fair.
Boards really matter to be a check.
Right on on companies and so I well,
I think we we all understand.
We all understand what a debacle
this was. My question to you.
Is something
that you tweeted about last night was
did the board previous board
at least succeed
in raising
public awareness of its fear of how fast
I was moving?
Too rapidly in their view.
Yes.
The cost was incredible.
But was that important?
Well, I would say it was damaging.
I think it was damaging.
And it put more powerful companies
in charge.
I think it did exactly the opposite
of the things they were saying.
I think it's going to accelerate
now quite a bit.
You know, there's ways
to make points about this.
Leaving the board
and making a statement or something like
that could have been effective
I thought this was just a ridiculous
Ron delay of of nonsense.
I called it a goat rodeo.
It was a waste of time.
And they still haven't said
why they fired Sam Altman.
Who's now the CEO again.
And you're going to put allegations
like that out there.
You certainly should have them.
Can I ask you about that?
Carol, this morning,
The Wall Street
Journal is reporting
that the
Altman and the previous board
have agreed
to internal investigations
into his firing,
his actions, all of that.
Why is it important for humanity to
Oh, I don't think
it's important for humanity.
I think it's just a cover.
It's a fig leaf.
This board is lost.
And so they'll look at it.
I think a lot of the stuff was
well known.
I think it was just a matter of,
you know, someone said,
is this a bigger issue or is it petty?
I think it's more petty
and egos than anything else.
And I think he was moving
faster than they liked.
And instead of dealing with it,
they did this dramatic thing.
And I don't know,
I felt like there was nine
other ways to do this,
but this is the way they went.
They couldn't even decide
on adding new board members previously.
So you know,
it was a dysfunctional board.
And now we have one
that presumably once it gets
bigger, will be more functional.
We'll see
once that once the women are added care
and then we'll see what happens
Yeah, yeah.
Kara Swisher, appreciate it.
And thank you for being so helpful
with us all week.
Thanks on this story.
And happy Thanksgiving, Carol.
Have a good one.
No problem.
Thank you.
And a Stewart is on this story.
So, Anna,
if people have just been away
and not plugged
in over the last six days,
it wouldn't look like this
was a major story.
And yet so much has changed.
Talk to us about Altman's decision
to come back to the company
and the change up in the board.
I mean, it's quite extraordinary.
This is actually
the fourth CEO
in less than a week, albeit a CEO.
He's rather familiar
because he was the CEO last Friday.
This has been
the most extraordinary few days.
Perhaps the least surprising
development of all, though, is
that Sam Altman is back,
even though
he was offered
a position at Microsoft on Monday
It was quite clear
when we had that open letter from well,
it was signed by almost
all of the workforce
at Open Air,
saying that they would resign
and also move to Microsoft
if the board didn't reinstate Sam Altman.
So really no surprise that he's back.
But there are some changes
that he's coming back to
that is naming, as he said, the board,
the board to responsible for firing him,
who were responsible for doing that
without
really any communication
with major investors like Microsoft.
So we've had a few changes.
One is still that Adam D'Angelo,
who was a member of the board
that took on the ousting of the CEO.
The other two
that we now have on New Day,
you can see that Brett Taylor
who is a former CEO of Salesforce.
And also, interestingly,
Larry Summers, former Treasury
Secretary in the US.
Perhaps that will speaks
to the relationship
that definitely needs to have
with governments
and regulators around the world.
So a few subtle changes there.
There is no doubt in my mind, though,
that the winners of all
this has been Sam Altman,
who has never been more valued
and in a stronger position.
And of course, Microsoft, the partner.
Yeah.
Microsoft owning some 49% of the company.
But does this address the issue
at the heart of this breakup
and then make up?
And that is the speed at which
AI has been growing.
I don't think it answers
or necessarily changes
anything other than it's
definitely brought that issue
to everyone's awareness.
If that was the true reason
why he was fired
and the board last week
were very cagey about why they fired him,
they actually said
that Sam Altman had been less
than candid
in his communication with the board.
It very much sounded
like he'd been lying.
There was no more detail than that.
But if this was about the speed of A.I.
and commercial losing it,
but also ensuring the safety,
that issue is definitely forefront
of everyone's minds.
And I think we'll still hear a lot
about that from Altman and Microsoft.
But they will, of course,
plow ahead
because this is the profitable
part of the business.
Would it be a fly on the wall
in a business school
trying to teach a course
and what just happened?
Anna, Stuart,
thank you so much for covering it for us.